Okay, so far we have talked about a lot
of things. You have built a back end and
it works well on a lot of ends. It has
authentication, it has database, it has
your handlers, your services, your
repositories, pretty much everything
that we have discussed so far in this
playlist. Now let's imagine a real life
scenario where a new requirement comes
in for your back end. And what is that
requirement? pretty straightforward and
practical. You have users in your
system. You have users in your database
and they need to upload files and the
files can be for many reasons but let's
imagine a very basic scenario. They want
to update their profile picture, right?
That's the whole requirement of why they
need to upload files. Now starting from
there if you want to implement this
let's follow our intuition without
knowing the right way without uh knowing
what is the production grade way and
what is the textbook way what comes to
our mind what is the intuitive way what
is the naive way of doing this we are
getting a file and we need to store it
somewhere the first thing that will come
to our mind is that you will take Take
that file and you'll take it how the
front end browser sends you the file
using something called as form data
which is what we use for sending files.
Then you extract that from the request
from the form data and you save it
somewhere in your local file system.
Why? Because it is a file and where do
we save files in our local file system?
because we are running a back end on top
of a system, a physical system which has
its own memory. It has its own CPU and
its own storage. So naturally we have it
in the storage which is a file system.
So assuming it is a Linux file system
because that's where most of the servers
are deployed. It can be something like a
FS or ext4 or any typical file system
that you might encounter in the wild.
After saving the file somewhere in our
local file system, the next obvious
thing to do is record where we stored
it. After the user has uploaded the
file, naturally the next request is
going to be to fetch the file back so
that the browser can render it and they
can see the profile picture in their
page. So we need to record the path of
where we stored that file in our back
end. So we save the file in the file
system, record the path in a database
and we are done. This is the most
intuitive and naive way we can imagine
of handling files in a typical back end.
And from my very obvious stone, you have
probably already guessed that this is
the wrong way. But let's keep at it.
Let's let's still humor ourselves and
see how and where it goes. And I have to
mention here that even right after
storing it in the next second when the
user requests a file back there is a
very good chance that our whole flow our
whole intuition breaks here which I'll
come back to for the sake of the
explanation. Let's keep going. Let's not
come to the list of problems yet. We'll
explore the list of problems one by one.
Okay. Let's assume that you have stored
the file and the path in the database
and everything worked. In the next
request when the user requested their
profile details, they got the path or
the file which is stored in the local
file system and you were able to send
the file back to the user and they were
able to render it in the browser in
their prov. Okay, happy case. Now let's
come to the first problem. Not
technically the first problem but the
first simple and obvious problem because
let's not get into the whole complicated
uh distributed system problem yet. Let's
start with the obvious one which is the
size of the file. Typically when users
upload for their profile pictures they
are small somewhere from 300 KB to a max
of 10 MB and if they have taken the
picture from their iPhones it can be in
that range. If it is from a very fancy
mirrorless camera then it can be let's
say 15 MB to 20 MB but still small
comparatively most of the time
everything fits into your servers memory
and there is no traffic spike of any
sort. So things work out pretty well. So
now that you have a pattern for dealing
with files in your back end a new
requirement comes in and here you have
to deal with videos. This can be
something like uh if you are a social
media site, the videos are probably for
their feed for users to post in their
feed or if it is some kind of a
messaging feature. Users want to send
videos to other users. In any case, you
need to deal with files and videos which
are typically very large. They can be as
small as a few megabytes or as big as a
few gigabytes. So let's say you use the
same pattern of getting the file from
the form data, saving it in your local
file system and saving the path in the
database for the video also. Now imagine
our first problematic scenario, the size
based problem of this whole pattern.
Let's say a user uploads a 4GB video to
your server and they want to post that
video in their feed. So they need to
upload that video. The moment that video
reaches your server, the moment you
start processing the request, a lot of
things happen and most of those things
are bad as you can guess. Talking about
a server, let's say you are a midsize
startup and each instance of your server
is around 4GB. We'll get to the multi-
instance part in a bit. And the instance
that starts processing this request is
provisioned with 4G of total memory. And
since your server has only 4 GB of total
memory and your framework, whatever you
are using very helpfully reads that
entire file into memory and hands it to
you. So for obvious reasons, your server
runs out of memory because it reads the
whole file into memory. Your memory is
empty and the container gets killed
instantly. So assuming you have set up
the whole production grade scaling
infrastructure which we have discussed
in our past videos, your container
automatically restarts. The moment it
restarts, every file that was ever
uploaded to this instance that you had
stored in your local file system is gone
completely. The profile pictures, the
videos and everything is wiped clean.
Why? Because containers file systems are
what we call as ephemeral. meaning the
storage is not persistent and not
permanent. It only lasts up to the point
when the container is restarted. The
moment it gets restarted, everything
gets wiped. And since we talked about
the scaling in our previous video, we're
assuming that you have scaled your
backend instances to let's say three
instances last month only to deal with
your user traffic and to deal with your
load. And turns out that even the files
that did survive because they got
uploaded to other instances, they only
survive in those instances. This
particular instance that we're talking
about which got killed and restarted, it
cannot access those files. So
statistically speaking, one out of every
three requests for a profile picture
returns a 404 status not found error. So
what went wrong? Why did this happen? It
was because of one wrong assumption that
we made which is that a file is
something our application owns which is
not true. A file is a data that is that
that has a completely different shape
from the data that we are used to
dealing with which is mostly JSON. Your
server 95% of the time it deals with
JSON and files are completely different
from that. They have a completely
different access pattern. a completely
different cost profile and for obvious
reasons for the failures that we just
noticed they need a completely different
kind of storage system and that is the
topic of this video because this
particular storage system is called
object storage and in this video we are
going to talk about object storage and
we'll see what object storage actually
is why does it exist what are the
trade-offs of using it and all sorts of
stuff. We'll look at how it works behind
the scenes. How exactly your data the
the bytes that are getting transferred
is actually laid out in your physical
drives. And of course, we are going to
solve the whole user uploading files to
your server problem properly the
production way which is to answer in one
word using pre-signed URLs and the whole
workflows around that. We'll also talk
about large files, how to deal with them
using multiart uploads and resumable
uploads. We'll talk about download size,
range requests, how video seeking
actually works and the whole cost
profile because this is one of those
areas of backend engineering where cost
is something that you have to keep in
mind when you are dealing with files.
Now, as usual, before we get to the core
topic, we have to cover a little bit of
the surrounding area. Before before we
talk about object storage and what it
actually is, let's spend some time on
why it exists. Because if you don't know
what exactly is the problem that it is
solving, what exactly is the pain point
it is fixing, then all the concepts that
we are going to cover, they will mostly
sound vague. they will mostly sound
theoretical and we'll have no motivation
to learn about a new technology to solve
the problem that we already have. So
let's break let's divide our motivation
into a couple of problems and we'll
cover one problem at a time. Now the
number one problem that is your service
disk is ephemeral which you just saw and
we have already covered that what
ephemeral means. It means that
everything all the memory the primary
memory secondary memory whatever you are
storing inside the server that only
lasts till you restart your container
till the next restart. That is more or
less what ephemeral means. So if you are
deploying your servers your backends
with docker and kubernetes with any of
the modern platform as a service
providers like railway render and if you
are going serverless then platforms like
versel netifi there are a lot of them
and we have pretty much covered all
these platforms deployments kubernetes
docker all this stuff in one of our
previous videos but anyway the point is
if you are deploying with docker and
cubern Kubernetes, then your application
is running inside a container. And as we
just saw, the container's file system
only exists as long as the container
exists because every time a container is
killed or every time a container is
restarted, a new container is booted up.
In place of that, the image is the same,
the container image is the same, but the
container instance is completely new.
And that is one of the reasons we call
it as stateless. Typically during
deployment when you push your code for
CI/CD deployments, you deploy a new
version of the image with the latest
version of your code and the old
container is destroyed. It is killed and
it is replaced with a completely new
container created from the latest
version of your Docker image which has
the latest code of your application or
your back end. Now this particular
image, this docker image, it does not
contain your users files. So every
single time you deploy all of your users
files, if you're storing them inside the
container file system, they are
completely wiped. So at this point, if
you are already familiar with how
Docker, Kubernetes, and the whole
container ecosystem works, you already
have a partial solution in mind, which
is attaching a persistent volume. Now we
have not covered Docker, Kubernetes and
the whole infrastructure world in this
playlist yet which is probably going to
the last video of this playlist. But a
persistent volume is basically any
storage that you attach to a container
for this precise problem that we just
saw the femoralness of the container.
Not the problem of storing users files
in the file system. That is not what it
is for even though you can use it. But
the problem of avoiding the issues of
whatever the storage being ephemeral
that is the solution persistent volumes
provide anyway if you are thinking about
persistent volumes which is fine you can
do that but even if you are using
persistent volumes it is still going to
fail on problems two and three which
we'll cover shortly. Now the second
problem is horizontal scaling. If you
have watched the previous videos and
your memory is still fresh even though
it should not be it's almost been a
decade since I uploaded the last video
but we have talked about all the scaling
performance and all this stuff. So let's
say you have three instances of your
server behind a load balancer which is a
completely normal thing to do and we
have discussed this in the scaling
video. So a user uploads a file and the
load balancer happens to route that
request to instance number one. The file
is returned to the instance one's disk,
its local file system because we are
still on the knife problem. We have not
gotten to the production way yet. So 2
minutes later, the same user requests
that file back because they uploaded the
file, navigated away to some other page
or they walked away from the screen.
Whatever happened they came back after 2
minutes and requested the file back
which basically means that uh the
browser is trying to render the profile
picture and it is asking for the files
data. So that goes through the load
balancer because it is the first point
of contact for our infrastructure. Now
the load balancer usually has algorithms
for how to route requests to different
instances. Let's say the algorithm that
was in use in this scenario was very
simple a roundroin algorithm which means
that it just rotates in order in a
particular order between all three
instances which means that the next time
this request goes to instance number
three for some reason because the last
request went to instance number two. Now
the problem is that instance three has
no idea that this particular file that
the user is requesting it exists. That
means that the server is going to return
404 not found. And the more you scale
out or the more horizontal scaling that
you do meaning the more instances of
your server that you keep adding because
of your user load and your traffic for
whatever reason the worse it is going to
get. The probability of hitting the
correct instance out of all these
instances depending on the algorithm the
load balancer is using is more or less
one divided by number of instances and
storing files on the instances local
file system. It breaks the single most
important property of a horizontally
scalable server which is statelessness.
Your server should never hold any state
that other servers do not have. Great.
Now comes the third problem. The disk is
of a fixed size and growing or
increasing in size is a vertical
operation which means that you cannot
keep adding more disks to your server.
You just have to increase the capacity
of your existing disks because as your
traffic grows you can add more instances
of your server to your infrastructure.
But disk is something that you have to
increase vertically not horizontally. So
for a disk you can only grow by making
the disk bigger which usually means that
you'll have some downtime. Why? Because
you have to disable the existing disk
increase the size and attach the new
disk with all the data copied more or
less these are going to be the steps in
any cloud infrastructure. Basically a
resize operation on your disk. And
another problem attached to that is
there is always going to be a ceiling
which means that there is always going
to be a maximum size of the disk that
you can add depending on the cloud
provider that you are using. Meanwhile
files that are getting uploaded by your
users are pretty much the fastest
growing data in almost every application
that you can imagine. A lot of users can
upload a lot of files at any instant at
any time throughout the day. So let's
say thousand users uploading 100 MB each
is going to be 100 GB a month of growth
forever and that is not going to shrink
because the number of times people
delete their files is far less than the
times they upload. Okay. Now the fourth
problem is durability because your
server has one disk and if that disk
dies and discs do die in real life for a
lot of reasons including power failure
some kind of hardware crash even our
personal system our personal laptops
even their discs failed sometimes. So it
is a completely normal and expected
operation that can happen at any time.
So if your disk dies which contains all
your users files all of those files are
gone since that was the only copy and
here I want to introduce two terms
availability and durability. What is
availability? Availability means that
whether you can reach a particular piece
of data right now. But durability means
whether your data still exists somewhere
somewhere in the world. If one copy of
your data exists somewhere then we can
call it durable. And the reason we are
introducing these terms now is to
explain that you can recover from an
availability problem by waiting. That's
the worst case scenario. If your server
is unavailable or it has some kind of
latency problem, your users just have to
wait and eventually the problem will go
away with some kind of fix and they will
get their data at that point of time.
But you cannot say the same for a
durability problem. You cannot recover
from a durability problem. At least not
by waiting because that data is gone.
That pile is gone from existence. And
pretty much everywhere in our tech
industry, the only solution to
durability is replication, which is just
a fancy term of keeping some piece or
some backup of your data somewhere else.
So at any point there should be multiple
copies of your data and the moment you
have these backups these copies you also
have things like check sums and you also
need background processes that can
detect when there is some kind of data
corruption and they need to fix it and
all these very hard engineering problems
replication check sums repair processes
it's a completely different engineering
area and is a very big area which is not
something that you want to tackle or
even think about when you're building
your small to-do app. So, not worth the
trouble. The fifth problem is that let's
let's forget about the uploads for a
while. Let's talk about downloads. After
saving the file, your server has to send
the file back whenever a user requests
it. Serving or sending a file back to
the user is also an operation which
involves your back end. So let's say a
file is of 50 MB and you have a user on
a mobile connection with a internet
speed of let's say around 2 MB per
second 2 mgabits per second not 2
mgabytes now that download the download
from the mobile is going to take around
3.5 minutes and for those 3.5 minutes
one of your servers workers if you are
using something like go then one of your
go routines and if you are using
something like nodej is then one of your
event loop workers. Whatever language
runtime that you're using, whatever
concurrency primitive that you're using,
that thing, that worker is just sitting
there and it is doing nothing but
copying data, copying bytes very slowly
to a internet deprived phone thousands
of miles away. That's the only thing
that is doing. And the reason it is a
problem is your server is not built for
that job. I mean of course it can do
that job and they they do it all the
time but that's not the best use of its
time because it is not a content
delivery network. CDN exist just to
solve this problem and in this case your
server it is a very expensive very slow
content delivery network with probably a
let's say 100 concurrent connection
limit and we discussed this shortly in
our concurrency video that your server
at any point of time is doing two
different kinds of work either it is IO
bound or it is CPUbound what does
CPUbound mean it means that it is using
the CPU simply ly speaking and doing
some kind of processing that requires
CPU. It is involving the actual CPU
coursees. And what does IOB bound mean?
It means it is either sending to some
other component like a database or a
external client, external API, external
server or reading files from your file
system or something. It is either
sending some data or waiting for data
from any of these. And we already know
that we don't like IO bound work. We
should avoid it as much as we can if we
can manage to do that. Okay. Now finally
the sixth problem which is a little hard
to wrap our head around that is files
and database rows they have no
transaction between them which means
that they are two completely different
systems. They have no control over each
other. And why are we saying this? Let's
imagine a scenario where you write the
file to disk and then take the path of
that file where it is stored in the disk
and insert that as a row into your
database. If the insertion fails, you
have a file on your disk but you don't
have a corresponding database row. So
the users have no way to access it. that
file is completely orphan and in the
worst case scenario it costs you just
more money because of that uh orphan
storage. But if we flip the scenario,
you do it the other way. You insert the
row into your database first right after
getting the file and then you try to
create the file on your disk in your
local file system. And if the file
creation fails, writing to disk fails.
Now you have a row in your database with
a column with a path which is invalid.
So every time the user tries to fetch
their profile picture, your server tries
to access that file from that path and
it throws an error. So depending on your
error handling logic, they either get a
500 or something like 404. And the
reason we have this scenario this uh
file system and database syncing
scenario is that we don't have any kind
of transaction. We don't have a way to
ensure that either both the operations
happen or both fail. We don't have any
control over both the systems at the
same time. And we'll come back to this
particular problem later in the video
because there is a pattern for it. And
right now I just want you to notice that
this problem does not really go away
when we start using the object storage.
But it just becomes a little easier to
solve. But object storage is not a
direct solution for this problem. Now
that we have established our intuitive
approach, our naive approach which
breaks in production at scale to
understand a little bit about the
context of the problem, we need to go
one level down and we need to ask a
question. What are the different kinds
of storage that are available to us? And
the answer is majorly three and each one
of them has their own set of trade-offs.
First one is block storage. The block
storage it gives you a raw array of
fixed size blocks. typically from some
of the famous file systems that we have
available like ext4bit and some of the
legacy ones and for Windows if you're
talking about NTFS etc. Typically these
blocks are around 5 12 bytes or 4 KB
each and each block has a number that's
pretty much the whole interface of block
storage. So at any point you can read or
write to block number let's say 9
million and it will allow you to do that
and there is no concept of a file a name
or a folder that is exactly what an SSD
is a solid state drive and that is what
services like Amazon EBS the elastic
block storage offers you. One of the
primary reasons people use EBS or block
storage is that it is the lowest level
interface and it is usually the fastest.
The typical latency that we see that we
encounter while using the storage is in
microsconds. That is why most of our
database systems like posgress or MySQL
sit on top of this block storage. They
still make use of file system but not in
the way that we use it as users. They
keep some kind of direct interface
between them and the block storage so
that they can keep that microcond
latency that we mentioned that block
storage offers. But the trade-off here
is that the interface of block storage
is so so basic, so primitive that you
cannot really build an application on
top of it directly. The second and it's
a critical limitation is a block device.
A block storage device can be attached
to exactly one machine at a time. You
cannot attach the same storage to
multiple machines for any kind of
sharing. Now the second kind which is
the file storage. Now the file storage
the file system is one abstraction on
top of block storage. On top of blocks,
a file system can build hierarchy of
things like directories or folders,
files, paths, permissions or iodes, all
these technical computer science file
system stuff. And in return, it gives
you a very rich interface which is full
of features. You can do a lot of
operations like opening a file or
closing the file, seeking to byte number
9 million or 5 million, overwriting four
bytes. Exactly four bytes in the middle
of a file, renaming a folder instantly
and atomically locking a file, appending
to it, updating it, whatever operation,
all these operations that we do every
single day through various applications
and through our finder, our file manager
or whatever. And all these operations
that I just mentioned, these are called
as PZIX semantics. And what exactly is
this PZIX? POSIX is just a standard a
standard for operating systems primarily
and it defines all the various
operations that a typical operating
system should offer and if the operating
system offers most of the POSIX
semantics then it is called POSIX
compliant. All these operations that we
just discussed are the file system
category under the POSIX semantics and
they are extremely convenient and as
usual convenience does come with a set
of trade-offs. All these operations that
are provided by our operating systems by
the file system they need coordination.
For example, a rename operation which we
do without even thinking twice. It has
to be completely atomic. Otherwise, a
lot of operations, a lot of system
operations will immediately break. A lot
of applications and systems depend on
this property of our file system that a
rename will be completely atomic in the
sense it will either go successful or it
will fail. There should not be any in
between corrupted partial state.
Similarly, a partial write it has to be
visible consistently. What does that
mean? So, if you are using an editor,
something like uh VS code, Sublime Text
or something like that and you start
making edits to a file, you start
editing your TypeScript or JavaScript or
whatever file. The moment you start
editing and before that file is saved,
VS code the the the VS code process
which is currently holding the file
handle for each edit it will create for
that edit operation it will create a
temporary file in whatever temporary
file location that your operating system
is offering and it will keep writing to
it and only after you hit save at that
point it will create a new file move all
the contents of the temporary file to
the new file and delete. both the old
and the temporary file. All these things
happen so that at any point of time if
someone tries to access the file they
either get the old version, the original
version before the edit or the
completely new version which is after
the edit, they never get the partial
state while the process is writing to
it. Similarly, two processes, two
applications in our operating system, if
they're writing to the same file, so
they need some kind of locking. This is
very famous in most of our log files
where where multiple programs are trying
to write to the log file and this
locking and coordination. This property
does not really scale across the network
boundary across data centers across
continents and that is exactly why
network file systems like NFS they exist
with of course their own set of
trade-offs. Now finally the last one the
third one which is object storage. Now
this starts from a completely different
question. So instead of asking how do we
give people the richest possible
interface or a large set of features, it
asks this question that what is the
absolute minimum interface we can get
away with. Why? So that it can scale to
unlimited capacity. It can scale to
xabyte or what we call as planet scale
which is just a way of saying that can
scale to the extent that no other file
system can at least when it comes to the
coordination problem. So what exactly is
this minimum interface that it comes
with basically four operations put an
object with a name or upload an object
with a name get an object by its name
delete the object by its name and list
all names. That's pretty much all of it.
Four operations. That's everything that
an object storage gives you when it
comes to the interface. Now, let's look
at the trade-offs here. First, you
cannot really modify an object in place.
You cannot update or append a file or
technically an object. Whatever we store
in the object storage, we call it an
object, not a file. We can call it a
file but in a technical sense it is not
really a file. It is an object because
when you call it a file you expect all
the features that typically come with
the name file which an object does not
offer. For example updating very much
expected from a file but it is not
offered by an object. Similarly, there
is no seek, there is no partial rate
that the files in your operating system
offer you. So, if you want to change one
bite in the middle of a 1 GB object,
what you need to do, you need to
download the whole 1GB file, make
whatever changes that you want to make,
then upload the whole 1GB file back with
the same key. Why? Because objects, as I
said, cannot be modified. They are
immutable. they can only be replaced.
Then there are no real directories, no
real folders. And why do I say there are
no real folders? In most of our object
storage providers to give people a sense
of folders, we have what we call as
prefixes in the object storage world
using which we can build a very minimal
file folder structure. But as I said, it
is just an illusion. And we'll come to
why I'm saying it is just an illusion.
Similarly, there is no rename in the
world of object storage. A rename means
you copy the whole thing to the new name
and then you delete the old one. And
because of that, a rename costs you the
complete size of the object that you're
trying to rename. Similarly, there is no
file locking like the kind of locks
offered by your operating system. And if
we look at the latency numbers, it is
not in microsconds which is offered by
your block storage and also your file
system. In object storage, it is at
least a few milliseconds or even tens of
milliseconds. Why? Because every single
operation that you perform in object
storage is an HTTP request that is going
over a network, it is crossing a network
boundary to a machine that is somewhere
in some data center. Now the question is
with all these trade-offs, all these
limitations that object storage offers,
why would anyone on earth use object
storage in the first place? What
advantage do they offer in return? to go
over a few of them. Since there is no in
place modification, there is no object
modification, there is nothing to
coordinate and because of that an entire
class of distributed systems problem are
completely eliminated. Second, there is
no hierarchy at all. No folders, no
directory structures. So there is no
tree to maintain, no tree to lock and no
tree to rebalance which all happens in
typical file systems the locking the
rebalancing the tree and all these
things. Third, every operation is a
self-contained HTTP request. And because
of that, any of the 10,000 servers
spread across the whole world can serve
any request, which is just a way of
saying that the system it scales
horizontally without any limit. Then
your capacity is pretty much infinite.
You never have to provision, you never
have to resize, you just keep uploading
your objects. And if you're using one of
the famous object storage systems like
Amazon S3, you also get the durability
guarantee which famously called as 11
9s. We'll come to what that 11 9s mean
and the whole mathematics side of it in
a little bit. Every object is directly
addressable via HTTP the HTTP protocol
which means that any system whether it
is a browser a C video player a mobile
app whatever system that speaks the H
protocol which is pretty much every
single device every single system in
this era they all speak HTTP whatever
computing device that you can imagine
and because of that all of them all
those systems can talk to can
communicate with object storage without
going through any servers in between. By
the way, just a footnote, this set of
trade-offs that we talked about, this is
not really unique to storage. If you
read about distributed systems, the same
set of trade-offs that we just saw is
also available when it comes to caching,
when it comes to stateless servers, when
it comes to immutable deployments. So in
distributed systems almost every time
you go to infinite scale every time you
want to achieve infinite scale the
tradeoff that comes with it is
mutability. You have to give up
mutability which means that modifying a
state of something in place that's what
we mean by mutability. So when it comes
to the larger distributed systems
ecosystem, object storage is just one of
the purest and one of the most famous
examples of that trade-off. Okay, now
enough about the context. Let's see
precisely what exactly an object is.
Let's explore that part from the
structure of it. So an object has four
things. A key which is a string. That
string is the complete and entire
identity of that object. Then a value
which is just an array of bytes just a
blob of bytes is binary. Then some
metadata which is things like the size,
the last modified time, the content type
and the e tag. And this is called system
metadata. There is also a section which
is called user metadata which are just
uh dynamic key value pairs that you can
attach as the user of the object storage
for your own server use cases. For
example, if you want to record who
uploaded that particular object, then
you can add a field called as uploaded
by where you can add the user ID which
is mapped to what is stored in your
database and that gets stored at the
object level in the object storage. All
of these objects they live inside a
bucket. A bucket is the term that we use
which is not exactly a folder but it is
something that exist one level up of
objects. Objects are stored inside a
bucket. So bucket is just a named
container and the bucket name combined
with the key of the object it has to be
globally unique. Which means that if we
talk about a particular cloud platform
like AWS, your bucket name has to be
unique across the whole platform. Now
let's talk about the biggest controversy
or the biggest gotcha of object storage
which is there are no folders, there are
no directories and there is no concept
of folders or directories. It is just an
illusion. So when you look at the AWS
console or your Cloudflare dashboard you
see a folder whatever folder you have
created something called let's say
uploads and if you double click it there
is another folder called 2026 and inside
that there is an image. This whole
hierarchy is just an illusion just a lie
which is created just to keep the
interface a little more intuitive
because that's what we are used to.
imagining our files inside a hierarchy.
What is actually happening behind the
scenes is that there is just one object
and its key is the whole string which is
uploads/2026/cat.png.
There is just one object and these
slashes are just any character in a
string that is just part of the name.
They do not really have any special
value. any other character like if you
want to replace with hyphen at the rate
or hash or whatever you can do that it
does not hold any special operational
value. The directory the folder that you
are seeing that is not exactly a
separate object. There is no concept of
a parent no nested level that is
happening here. It is just one bucket
with millions billions and trillions of
string keys inside. That's pretty much
the whole concept. to take a look at
this uh whole illusion. Let's say I put
one object using AWS CLI with this name
and this key has slashes in it after
uploads and after 2026.
Now if you look at the dashboard, it
shows two folders and it pretty much
invented both of them. It is just as I
said an illusion. the raw listing if we
check using the CLI it shows what is
actually there which is just one key one
string and when I ask for the prefix
with a delimiter the folder will show up
in a field called common prefixes that
that's array that you're seeing that is
the entire folder feature that we have
if you look at this when I ask for a
prefix of uploads slash and a delimiter
of slash The server finds every key in
the whole bucket that starts with that
prefix and for each one of them it looks
at the rest of the string and if the
rest of the string contains the delimter
it chops it from there and it reports it
once as a common prefix. That's pretty
much the whole algorithm of how it is
constructing this whole idea of folders.
Folders are just a group by algorithm if
you can imagine it on a string. And this
is exactly why moving a folder inside a
bucket takes a long time and it also
costs you money. Why? There is no folder
to move in in the first place. There are
these 40,000 individual objects and they
each have to be copied to a new key and
the old ones have to be deleted. And
that is the same reason you cannot have
an empty folder. Why? Because the
folders themselves have no identity in
the object storage. An empty folder is
something which is conceptually
technically impossible to exist. But
there are some tools and workflows to
fake the whole empty folder thing by
creating a zero byte object whose key
ends with a slash. And because of the
algorithm does that whole chopping
thing, you can technically fool the
system into having an empty folder. But
internally it is just a zero byte
object. Now let's talk about the design
of the key. This is one of the most
common places where a back end engineer
who is dealing with object storage has
to make a real decision about the key.
And since key is the entire identity of
the object, there has to be some thought
put into it. So rule number one which is
also non-negotiable.
Never use the file name that the user
gave you as the key of the object.
Never. Why? Because there are there are
three separate reasons for this. The
first one is collisions. If two users
upload the same ré pdf, the second one
will silently replace or destroy the
first one's file. Why? Because the
operation you use to upload a file into
object storage is called a put operation
for a reason. And if you have watched
the HTTP video, we already know that the
put rest API operation. The put method
is used when you want to replace a whole
entity with another entity. That is why
object storage uses the word put. They
don't use post which is for creating a
new entry always. That is a promise of
post. When you send a new object with
the same key, what it will do? It will
overwrite whatever object that already
exists with the same key and it will not
throw any error. It will not give you
any warning that it replaced something.
It will just do the replacing silently.
Second problem, the second reason is
path traversal. A file name can contain
any characters including dots and other
special characters. And depending what
you do with that downstream, this can
completely escape the prefix you thought
you were writing into the folder that
you are writing into and that will
create other problems. And finally, if a
user is uploading a file, it can contain
anything. It can contain an emoji, a
right to left override character. It can
also contain null bytes. Pretty much
whatever you can imagine that can come
from a random user. And if something
like that is present in the name then it
can become a bug in your system in your
back end. So what is the solution? What
is the right way to design the key?
Generate the key yourself for that is
the first thing. Ideally something
random and store the original file name
that the user gave you somewhere in your
database. And if you want you can also
store it in the user metadata inside the
object at the object storage level. The
only time that you will use this
original file name is when someone asks
for the same file. Second rule is for
designing the key is anything random
that you want to put inside the key.
Always put it at the front not at the
back because a lot of people write keys
like upload slash then a time stamp then
the ID and the problem with that is the
object storage system. It partitions the
index by the key prefix. And because
it's a huge sorted index, we'll talk
about the index in the next section. If
every key you write in the next 1 hour
starts with the same prefix and it will
because you are using the time stamp,
the hour will be same for the next 1
hour. So all the files that you upload
for the next 1 hour, it will keep
hitting the same index partition. And
that's what people mean when they say
hot partition. And typically it ends up
as give throwing uh 503 slowdown errors
when there is a lot of traffic. So what
is the fix? simple which is put
something highly random early in the key
and technically it is called high
entropy which means that uh in very
simple terms very random something like
a UYU ID or some user ID which is
generated or maybe the first few
characters of a hash something like that
which is proven to be random so instead
of something like date/ user/file
you'll do something like user/tenant
ID/U ID even though AW WS itself has
improved the automatic partitioning a
lot over the last few years. You will
probably not face this issue at your
scale at a small scale but it costs you
literally nothing to do it the right way
from day one instead of trying to fix
the whole strategy once you reach the
scale. Now rule three which is now this
is a personal one that is make the key
carry the ownership. What does that
mean? If your key is something like
tenant ID/ user ID/object ID, then your
authorization check at your middleware
level, it can just be a string
comparison and that you can do before
you even talk to the object storage or
S3 and you can write your access policy
so that it scopes a set of credentials
to exactly one prefix. But if your keys
are just random UU ids in a very flat
name space, pretty much every
authorization check that you need to do,
it has to go through your database. So
by doing this small naming decision, you
can skip one network hop. Okay, now that
we know the interface, it's time to go
behind the interface to find the answer
to the question that when you send a put
request with a 100 MB file, what exactly
happens behind the scenes? The first
thing that happens is your request lands
on one of the thousand thousands or
millions stateless front-end nodes that
is served by AWS S3. Since we are
talking about AWS S3 primarily, it's one
of the most famous object stoages. So,
one of those nodes authenticates the
request which means it recomputes the
signature. We'll come back to the
signature part. Now at this point the
system splits into two completely
separate problems and that separation is
one of the most famous core
architectural idea of a object storage.
So what is that separation? Two things
one metadata plane two the data plane.
The data plane's job is to take the 100
MB of bytes and store them so that they
survive they exist. they don't die. Now
the metadata plane's job is to remember
that the key of upload/2026/cat.png
in this bucket maps to those particular
pieces of data in those particular
places and these two systems they have
completely different characteristics.
The data plane it deals with huge
volumes but very simple operations no
complexity here. The metadata plane on
the other hand deals with a very small
volume. It is compared to the data
plane. But the number of operations are
huge, countless number of operations.
And the most important fact is it needs
to be strongly consistent and extremely
fast. Now pay attention to this phrase
which is strongly consistent. We'll try
to cover this in a bit more thorough
manner later. to explain in one
paragraph. This is one of the concepts
of distributed systems which is
eventually consistent and strongly
consistent. Strongly consistent means
that if one of the users made or
uploaded a file to the storage system,
then any other user doing a read
operation or trying to fetch that same
file is guaranteed to get a successful
result even if they do it the very next
second. That's what it means by being
strongly consistent. On the other hand,
eventually consistent means that if some
user adds a file, some user uploads a
file, there will be some latency, there
will be some delay before another user
can fetch it. There will be some gap
between the last write and the latest
read. So between these two planes, the
storage system and the metadata plane,
the metadata plane is the harder
engineering problem. Why? Because
storing xabytes on drives has been a
solved problem for decades. But
maintaining a strongly consistent
globally distributed sorted index over
hundreds and trillions of keys where a
single lookup or fetch has to be just a
few milliseconds. That is a extremely
hard problem to solve. Even at the scale
of AWS, countless production systems
that we see today, they all depend on
the single characteristic of object
storage which is strongly consistent.
And since the data plane is
comparatively the easy problem to solve,
let's cover that first. The naive way to
make data durable as we have already
discussed is replication. These are just
buzzwords. But durable just means that
whether the data exists somewhere in the
world or not. Whether it exists or it is
completely gone and permanently deleted.
That's what durability means. At least
the data exists somewhere in the system
somewhere in the world. Replication
basically means that it is a different
copy of that data. Intuitively speaking,
if you want to make your data durable or
in a simple manner of speaking, if you
want to make your data available at
least somewhere in this whole world,
then naturally it has to have a backup
which is replication. You keep three
copies on three different machines
ideally in three different failure
domains. This means that if some kind of
failure happens, it cannot affect all
the three different machines at the same
time. This whole architecture works. It
is pretty simple. If one machine dies,
you copy the same data from another
machine. But what is the problem here is
the cost. To store one pabyte of
customer data, you have to buy 3 pabyte
of drives, right? Because you need three
copies. So that is almost 200% of
overhead. And when you have billions of
customers, that is almost billions of
dollars just for the replication. To
solve that problem, to solve the problem
of cost, these large object storage
providers, they use this technique
called erasure coding, which means that
you take the object and you split it
into let's say 14 shards, 14 different
parts and you run a mathematical
formula, a mathematical transformation
over these 14 different parts or shards.
And there's this algorithm called read
solomon. It's a classic algorithm and it
produces six additional parts which is
also called as parity shards. So now you
have 20 shards in total. You had 14
earlier and six additional parts were
created by this algorithm. Now what you
do, you spread, you scatter those 20
shards across 20 different drives in
different racks, different sections of
your data center in completely different
power domains so that the power failure
does not affect all the drives at once.
You keep them in different different
buildings ideally. But the the special
property the magical property of this
whole eraser coding is is that any 14 of
those 20 parts if you have even one of
those parts out of the 20 any one part
out of those 14 are enough to
reconstruct the original object
completely. It does not matter which of
the 14 parts that you have in your
position but you can construct the
complete object because of the
algorithm. It is pretty magical what you
can do with mathematics. So let's run
the numbers on this. 20 shards for 14
shards of real data is about 1.43 times
the overhead versus our earlier which
had three times for replication. Almost
half the cost. And at the same time it
can tolerate six simultaneous failures
instead of two. On top of that it's also
cheaper because you need a less number
of drives and it is more durable.
But what you pay for this is the CPU.
The CPU to compute this whole parity
thing, this whole algorithm plus the
extra reads that you do on recovery. But
the drives are more expensive when it
comes to the overall cost as compared to
CPU operations. So it's a pretty good
trade. Okay. Now coming back to
something I mentioned earlier, AWS S3
has this famous promise of 11 9s. 11 9
of durability which means 99.9999999%.
And what that number means is roughly
speaking that if you store 10 million
objects you should statistically expect
to lose one of them once every 10,000
years which sounds pretty ridiculous but
that's what that number means. And that
number is calculated from the whole
shard math that we did above. And one
more thing that I want to mention is
durability does not really mean backup.
It is something that I say to wrap your
head around the whole concept to
simplify the concept of durability but
strictly speaking it is not a backup. So
the 11 9s that AWS S3 promises you it
protects you against the drives getting
destroyed or dying but they do not
protect you against the actions you
take. Which means that if you run a
delete operation on a wrong prefix which
you did not want to do but you did it
for some system bug or some user
programmer bug then the system will very
durably very reliably and very
accurately with 11 9ths of confidence
delete all your data all the data
associated with the prefix. Now the
distinction here I wanted to make is it
is not a backup because after doing this
disaster you cannot ask it since the
data is durable I want my data back
because you have a backup that is not
how it works if you delete your data you
are not going to get it back that's why
I wanted to explain that durability does
not mean backups similarly if your app
has a bug and because of that it
overwrites a few objects and if that
happens you can have 100% trust in the
system in the storage system that it
will every time store the corrupted
version. It is not going to give you
back the original version. So if the
data matters it is important something
that you can do which is offered by AWS
S3 or some of the object stoages are
turn on versioning and if you do that
what it gives you is if you do any kind
of overwriting or some delete operation
on top of an object a new version of
that object gets created instead of
destroying or changing the old version.
to deal with that wrong prefix deletion
thing. What you can do is you can set up
your own replication to a second bucket
ideally in a different cloud account in
a different AWS account because if your
credentials are compromised then you
don't want the attacker to have access
to both the accounts at the same time.
So those two things are some of the
preventions that you can do to avoid
cases like that. Okay. Now let's talk
about the hard engineering problem which
is the metadata plane. Now conceptually
speaking it is just a huge sorted key
value index. You can imagine it as a
distributed B tree also called as a
balance tree. If you are familiar with
data structures and algorithm concepts
you might have heard of B tree. B tree
is also something that is heavily used
by various databases. One of the most
famous data structures that we have. So
you can imagine it as a distributed
balance tree that maps a bucket plus the
key to the location of the shards plus
the size and the e tag and the content
type and all of it. So the index that we
are talking about is partitioned by the
key range which is why we talked earlier
about the hot partition issue. So
because of that property because of that
uh structure if you run a list operation
on an object storage bucket let's say it
is pagenated at thousand keys that is
going to become very slow why because it
is a range scan over a distributed
sorted index if you can imagine it. So
range scans are fundamentally very
different and they're more expensive
than a straightforward lookup. Which
brings us to the single most important
rule in this area which is never use a
list operation. Never use a list method
as part of the request path. And what
that means is your database should be
the index of what files exist in your
bucket. The bucket is where you store
the file where the data lives. But if
you have to call the list objects API on
top of the bucket every time to answer
the question of what files exist for
this user in the bucket, that is
something that is not going to scale
very beautifully and it is going to
cause a lot of latency issues. And this
property also explains why there is no
atomic rename in an object storage. Why?
because rename would mean that changing
a key in the index while the data is
still the same. Now that sounds easy but
the key itself decides the partition and
that's why it's hard which also explains
why the object storage can tell you the
object's size instantly without uh
touching a single drive or checking the
size of it. Historically S3 was
eventually consistent which means if you
uploaded an object and immediately did a
get request for that object you will get
a 404 not found. This is because the
read request used to hit an index
replica that is not yet updated with the
latest state. That exact behavior used
to cause a lot of pain across a lot of
industries or a lot of systems. Now
starting from December 2020 the behavior
changed and now it is what we call as
strong read after write consistency. So
what that means is if you upload a file
it returns a 200 status even if you
request the file right after the next
second. So if you go through some of the
old blog post or old stack overflow
answers you'll see a lot of people
recommending things like retry loops or
sleeps after uploading the file. so that
you don't get a 404 status right after
requesting it. But now that pattern is
uh completely outdated because S3
natively supports strongly consistent
patterns now. Okay. Now let's talk about
my favorite and one of the most
fascinating behaviors in object storage
especially in AWS S3 which has this
behavior. And this is also one of the
reasons there is a lot of buzz around
write ahead log on top of S3 these days
on Twitter. if you're active there and a
lot of distributed systems building on
top of S3 is because of this single
feature which is conditional rights and
this is pretty recent for the last
almost 20 years object storage had no
such behavior of compare and swap. So
for an upload request or a put request
for a file or an object it always
overwrote any existing ones. So if two
different processes wrote to the same
key at the same time, one of them would
silently win and the other one would
fail. And that is not a problem. But the
problem is there was no way to detect
the failure. There was no way to find
out which of the two process actually
was successful. There was no way to
define this condition programmatically.
That only write this if does not already
exist. only write this if it does not
already exist. So that that behavior
changed in 2024 when S3 added the
feature of conditional rights. Now you
can send an upload request or a put
request with a header called if none
match and set the value to star which
means that create this object only if
this key does not already exist. If it
does exist, you get a 412 status code
which means precondition failure instead
of it silently overwriting any existing
ones. There is also another header
called if match which takes an e tag and
you will use this one when you want to
express the intention of replacing the
object only if its current content is
still what I read. And that expression
helps us implement the compare and swap
operation that we talked about earlier.
So to explain a very simple scenario
when you might need the if match header,
let's imagine there are two clients,
client A and client B. Client A reads
the object from S3 and S3 gives it a
unique E tag with some kind of
fingerprint. So imagine it as some kind
of ID. So client A modifies the file
locally. then sends a write request
let's say a put request which contains
the if match header with the value of
the original E tag it got from S3 when
it reaches S3 what does S3 do if the
object's E tag it is sending matches the
E tag S3 also contains it will be a
successful operation and S3 will commit
that update and it will generate a new E
tag for that but in the meantime while
client A was working on the file locally
and before client A's request reached
S3, if client B also updated the same
file, client B's update request reached
the S3 before client A's request reach
S3. In that case, S3 has already updated
that object's E tag with client B's
request. And because of that, client A's
put request will fail with a 412 status,
which means precondition failed. And
what exactly is the benefit of this
whole interaction that we talked about?
Previously, depending on whose right
request reached S3, either client A's or
client B's, their right would have
persisted. The client whose right
request reached S3 earlier would have
lost their right. Now since we have this
condition, client B's data which would
have been lost without this comparent
swap feature is secure because S3
protects it using this whole if match
header and E tag. If we take a look at a
demo here using AWS CLI, the same
command that we're tying the first one
returns 200 and an E tag here. The
second one when we try the same request
now it returns a 412. Why? Because in
the earlier one the object was already
created. But since we are attaching this
header which is if none match with star
we are saying that only upload this
object if it does not exist in the
object storage. And since it already
exists because of the earlier command it
throws us the 412 error right in the
next line. And this 412 error that you
are seeing this is a huge deal. This is
what we call as a distributed lock in a
distributed file system concept. This
whole interaction this is a huge deal
for distributed systems as I have
already mentioned and a lot of systems
built on top of S3 depend on it because
of these two headers which enable the
conditional write property. Object
stories now has a primitive on top of
which you can build the whole
coordination interaction and because of
that people are doing a lot of different
fancy things on top of object storage
like distributed systems and leader
elections and even databases are using
object storage for their write ahead
logs. Why? Because now you can guarantee
that exactly one writer wins because of
this whole conditional write property
and that is the number one requirement
for a right ahead log. On top of that
combined with the strongly consistent
property that we just saw of object
storage they are perfect for being the
storage of a right ahead log. So for the
sake of this video to make it easy to
visualize the scenario the immediate use
for us is far simpler. So what is the
immediate value? Now you can guarantee
that an upload by any client by any user
never silently corrupts any existing
object which in turn protects you from
the whole duplicate key bug that we
talked about earlier. One disclaimer in
the cloud market there are a lot of
object storage providers
and a lot of them claim to be S3
compatible. That is one term that you
will hear a lot in the object storage
ecosystem. S3 compatible. What that
means is in one line that roughly
speaking that they support the same
protocol as AWS S3. For example,
Cloudflare R2 is called S3 compatible
because you can use the AWS SDK to
interact with Cloudflare's ecosystem.
Cloudflare R2 to be precise. That is
what people mean when they say S3
compatible. The S3 compatible does not
always mean that they support this
critical feature which is conditional
right. For example, back blaze which is
also a very famous consumer object
storage provider but it does not support
conditional write even though it is S3
compatible. So before depending on this
critical feature you need to check the
documentation to see whether even though
they are compatible the object storage
has the conditional feature or not
conditional write feature or not. Now we
get to the part where we answer how does
a file actually get from a user's laptop
into your object storage into your S3
bucket. Now there are two architectures
for this. First one is through your
server. This is the obvious one where
the browser posts the file to your API.
Your back end receives it and it
forwards it to the S3 bucket in the
object storage. Your back end sees every
bite. So it can validate the content
properly, scan it, compute the hash if
it wants to, and it can reject it for
any reason before it reaches object
storage. And any kind of authorization
that you'd implement here is just your
normal authorization middleware. No,
nothing fancy. You won't have to
configure any kind of additional course
or anything like that. And mostly for
small files like profile picture, CSV
files, documents under a few megabytes,
this can be fine. And we do use this
pattern sometimes and there is no
objective way to say that this is a
wrong pattern because it does work for
small files and there is no denying
that. But there is a problem hiding in
this one and the problem is buffering.
For example, if you call something like
parse multipart form in a language like
Go or you use the default body parser in
a node web framework, the entire file
gets read into the memory into the RAM
of your server. What happens with that
is a 100 megabyte upload is obviously
100 megabytes of memory. We already know
that. So if you have 20 concurrent
uploads which means 20 users uploading
files at the same time and each one is
100 megabytes you can easily exhaust the
2GB memory threshold that you have
instantly and which brings us back to
the same problem that we faced at the
beginning of the video. Your container
hits its memory limit depending on how
much memory you have assigned to the
container. It can also get killed
because of the out of memory error and
it has to be restarted. Out of memory
error is very famous for containers. The
tricky part with this pattern is that
while you are developing locally, it is
not visible. This whole issue of
container running out of memory. Why?
Because your local development you
usually test with small files or a
couple of small files and your
connection is usually fast connected to
100 MPS networks
and your machine where you are doing the
development is usually very powerful
more than 16 GB of RAM. So nothing
really causes any problem. But the
correct implementation if you are going
with this pattern is to stream the data
so that you never hold the whole file in
memory. You read from the request body
in chunks and write those chunks to the
storage client using Amazon S3 SDK or
whatever you are using as they are
arriving so that your memory usage is
just one buffer, one small part of your
whole memory block. That is typically a
few kilobytes regardless of how large
the actual file is. whether it is 1
mgaby or 1 GB. So in go it would look
something like this. You are using the
multiart reader directly getting a part
as a reader and handing that reader to
the uploader. So you are delegating
without involving memory too much rather
than parsing the whole form. And in
pretty much every language, one safety
mechanism you should have is to wrap the
body in a size limit before you even
begin to read anything from it. So that
this whole class of error never happens.
If a client sends a 4GB of data or 4 GB
of file, they get cut off at your limit
instead of being allowed to try. So if
we take a look at a demo for this whole
inmemory thing, we have two servers and
both of them are uploading the same 500
MB file twice and we have this program
called BTOP and we are watching the
process to monitor the memory. First one
buffered version which means that it
reads the whole file into memory before
sending it to storage. So as you can see
the memory column on the right side it
is climbing as the body is arriving into
the server. So by the end of it it ends
up folding about 500 mgabytes more than
it started with. Now if you try the
streaming version the same file the same
client and the time is also the same
which is 6 and 1/2 seconds but this one
only holds a single chunk at a time. So
now if you look at the memory, it is
pretty flat. The line barely moves. And
that is the whole difference between
holding the whole file into memory and
just passing it through. And even with
streaming, this particular technique has
some limits that you cannot get around
because your bandwidth is now the
bottleneck. Your load balancer typically
has an idle timeout of let's say 60
seconds by default in most cases. And if
it is a slow mobile connection, it will
most likely hit the limit unless you
have increased the default idle timeout.
Similarly, if you are using a reverse
proxy, most likely something like
EngineX or Caddy or the popular ones. It
also has a body size limit and EngineX
is pretty notorious for the 413 error
which is request entity too large. And
the reason is exactly this scenario. And
if you're using a serverless function or
an API gateway, you also have a hard
payload cap of a few megabytes. And that
is something you cannot even raise. So
all in all, this architecture works in
some scenarios if you're lucky with
small files for some traditional
servers, but it is not recommended. It
is not something that we call production
grade architecture. Which brings us to
the second architecture which is the
pre-signed URLs which is the right
architecture the right pattern to
implement it. The solution to all the
problems that we saw is to let the
browser talk directly to the bucket
instead of us instead of us delegating
or acting as a relay server. We just let
the browser talk to the bucket so that
the data the bytes never go through our
server or touch our server. But the
problem is that in most production
systems the bucket is private and it
should be that is the right thing to do
because making your bucket public is a
major security risk. So it has to be
private and on top of that obviously we
cannot really give our AWS S3 or storage
credentials to the browser also
directly. Now the problem is how to give
a client a browser permission or
capability to talk to the bucket and to
communicate with it without any security
risk. And it needs to be able to do
exactly one operation on exactly one
key, one object for exactly the next 5
minutes without leaking any kind of
credential. And that exactly is the
answer this architecture has which is
pre-signed UR. It's a very beautiful
architecture. Solves the problem in a
very graceful manner. Now a pre-signed
URL is just a normal URL with a bunch of
query parameters. An algorithm, your
access key ID, your timestamp, an expiry
which is written in seconds, a list of
which headers are covered, signature
which is an HMAC, a keyed hash, and it
is computed over a string that describes
the request which is an H method, the
bucket, the key, the expiry and pretty
much all of it. All of that is hashed
with your secret key. So looking at the
flow, the browser works this way. It
sends a put request to that URL and the
storage service your Amazon S3 takes the
request and it rebuilds the same string
from it. It computes the HMAC with its
own copy of the secret and it tries to
compare both of them. If the match then
the request is passed through and it is
authorized. But if the browser changes
even one character of the key or the
method or it tries to use it after the
expiry, the recomputed hash, the
recomputed signature will not match and
it gets rejected. And this whole thing
completely solves our problem which is
the credential never leaves our server
but the browser gets the capability to
communicate with our bucket without any
security risk. to see a demo for this
presign URL thing. We have a page here,
a front-end app which is talking to S3
through our server. So first thing is
the page asks our own server for a
signed URL and this is what it comes
back the algorithm the credential the
date an expiry of 60 seconds and the
headers it covers and the signature at
the end. Now we try to upload with it.
So if you look at the network panel, the
request is a put request straight to the
bucket's own domain, not to our server
and it carries no credentials at all.
And the status that comes back is 200,
which means it is stored successfully.
Now there is a button here which when we
click it simulates the whole thing which
is wait 60 seconds and send exactly the
same request again. And when we do that
we get a 403 forbidden error because the
URL is dead now. And similarly if we try
another experiment here which is a URL
which is still alive but we change one
single character of the key. That's what
this button does and when we click on it
the signature does not match and the
bucket refuses it with the 403 error.
Now there is a bug hidden in this
architecture which is you generate a
pre-signed upload URL for a user who
says that they want to upload a profile
picture. Now the question is what is
stopping the user from uploading a 5GB
file to that URL? Nothing because the
signature covers the method the bucket
the key but no one really enforces the
size limit of the body. So what is the
solution for that? That is a pre-signed
post URL with a policy. So instead of
signing a URL, you sign a small JSON
policy document and hand the client back
a URL plus a set of form fields. And
that policy form will contain the
conditions. What kind of conditions? The
important one here is the content length
range, which is a hard minimum and
maximum size enforced by the object
storage service itself. Our server does
not have to get involved in that. We
delegate that responsibility to the
object storage. On top of that, you can
also enforce the requirement that the
content type should start with something
like image slash if you want. You can
also enforce that the key starts with a
specific prefix so that the client
cannot write outside their folder to
bypass any of the security restrictions.
And if the client violates any of these
conditions, the object storage itself
rejects the whole request and you will
get this entity to large error. The data
will never get stored. This is what it
looks like on the server. There are
three conditions. A size range between 1
kilob and 5 mgaby. A content type that
has to start with an image and a key
that has to start with this tenant and
user prefix so that it cannot escape.
And on the client side, if we take a
look at this, two things that we have to
mention, which is the file field has to
be appended last in the form data and
should not set the content type on the
fetch. It should let the browser set the
multiart boundary itself. Now coming
back to our earlier demo, we have the
same page but a second tab. We have two
rounds. Round one, let's do the knife
flow. The page asks for a pre-signed UR
for a profile picture. And then instead
of uploading an image of a few
kilobytes, it uploads 300 megabyte file
instead. So if you look at the network
panel, this is an actual put request.
300 mgabytes of file going straight into
the AWS S3 bucket. And it approves it.
It takes the file. It stores it. We get
the 200 status code. And now the bucket
holds 314 million bytes from a URL that
was signed for a profile picture which
is obviously wrong. Now round two the
same file but this time the URL comes
with a policy and now if we try it we
get a 400 which is entity too large and
nothing is stored in our S3 bucket. Now
with the policy if we try with another
file which is around 415 kilob image
with the same policy now it goes through
the file is stored because it matches
the policies size condition. Similarly,
if we try to enable this toggle which
tries to upload it in a different users
prefix and this time we get another
error which is 403 again and S3 refuses
it and it also tells us the exact
condition of why it failed. The last
piece of the upload problem is one of
the problems we discussed at the
beginning of the video, which is if the
browser uploads directly to the storage,
how does the server know about it? It
will never see the upload happen, right?
If the server never sees it, how will
the database find about it? How will it
store the path or whatever it needs to
fetch it the next time? Because later on
when the they issue a get request to
fetch their profile picture or their
video we can refer to the particular
database row and column to find the S3
object storage path fetch the file from
the object storage and return it. But if
you don't know the exact key we cannot
serve it and the answer to that is a
two-phase flow. First the client the
browser it asks the backend for an
upload. The backend authorize it,
verifies it and generates the key for
the object beforehand. It creates the
name beforehand which is going to be the
identity of the object and it writes a
database row with the status pending. It
also saves the key and whatever other
expected conditions and constraints. In
return, it sends back the pre-signed
post URL back to the browser. Before any
data moves from the client to the
server, the database already has a
record of the intent of the client with
the identity of the object. Now the
client, the browser starts the upload.
After the upload is finished, it calls a
completion API on your back end with the
upload ID it got from the phase one, not
the key, the upload ID. Then the server
initiates a head request, a head object
to be precise, to the object storage in
S3. And this head call this is just a
metadata call and it does not really
cost anything. What it does is it
verifies whether the object actually
exists whether the size is within the
expected range and whether the content
type is expected or not. When all these
conditions are passed in database we
change the status from pending to
something like completed or ready. Now a
logic hole here is we need some kind of
cleanup workflow some kind of cleanup
path. Why? Because some percentage of
these uploads will get abandoned because
of various client behaviors, connection
errors or browsers getting cut off from
network or the tab closing whatever can
happen because it is client set which we
don't have any control over and if it is
a slow network or a mobile network there
can be hundreds of reasons why the file
did not get uploaded or the file got
uploaded but the completion API never
got called and there are various
scenarios that can happen for that. And
we usually have a life cycle rule on the
bucket that deletes anything under the
pending prefix after 24 hours. Usually
with a small background job. We have
already covered background jobs in a
previous video. And that background job
scans all the pending rows from the last
24 hours and it marks them as expired.
And this job is pretty important because
it keeps your database and your object
storage from drifting apart from the
issue of having different sources of
truth. Because your database is the
source of truth for what files exist and
the bucket is the source of truth for
the actual data of the files, the actual
bytes. And anytime those two different
systems disagree, we need some kind of
background job to clean that up, to
resolve that.
One more small thing that will help you
avoid any confusion later is related to
course. Whenever we are talking about
the browser course will always come up.
So when a browser uploads directly to a
different origin which is three,
Cloudflare R2, back blaz B2 or whatever
object storage service that you're using
it is a cross origin request. That's
when course gets triggered. So for that
request to be successful, your object
storage bucket should have a course
configuration that explicitly allows the
front-end site origin, your front end's
domain. It should allow the put or post
method and it should also expose the E
tag header. We'll cover the use of the E
tag header in the next section where
we'll need this header for the multi-art
uploads also. So if your upload works in
curl in your terminal or in Postman but
it fails in your browser then most
likely it is because of the course and
you should probably check your bucket's
course policy.